the story I have for you today you could
say has a character me and some other
people who are very important in my life
family members friends perhaps and you
know
co-workers and it's a story about times
but really about Seasons about a
particular season that of winter
experienced mostly here in Wisconsin and
we could say also in the Midwest and
even over in a similar environment of
Southern Germany when I was in the Army
and it's a story about cold primarily
about being cold about cold weather
which has been changing over time you
know when we talk about global climate
change or global warming it is
definitely been taking place here in the
Midwest we don't get anything like the
snow that we used to in the past and
it's not as cold for most of the winter
we can you can tell that climate change
is actually occurring just by looking
out the window and walking down the
street so back up to what we actually
thought was a cooling period the 70s I
was born in 1970 and my earliest
memories are from the early 7 s when we
lived uh here in the Milwaukee area in a
place called Thiensville and then we
moved out to the
countryside just north of Wales
officially in the township of Delafield
but not in the town of Delafield and we
lived in a subdivision that we my my
parents built a house in I think they
were the third people to build a house
in that subdivision and then it it took
a long time for the subdivision to
actually fill up it was mostly
Countryside for years and years and it
was called the hills of
Delafield and this would cover the time
when I was in uh some preschool I was
actually in a monu preschool when I was
a kid and then in in Delafield in Wales
I was in kindergarten and then you know
first grade through um 11th grade and we
moved to wakasa after that which was a
little bit warmer at that time time and
we're talking about the the late 80s
right so in the early 70s we moved into
this place and you know my parents had
the money to build the house they didn't
have the money to completely finish the
house so for quite a long time there
were bare boards that you know we didn't
have carpet or tile or anything like
that I think we had tile in the bathroom
and maybe in the kitchen but carpets
would have to wait until my dad actually
made enough money with his job to make
that happen and we did have a nice big
fireplace a Fieldstone fireplace in the
living room and the years that we
originally moved in man it was cold I
remember and we had central heat which
was really kind of a blessing you know
my sister and I my sister's about two
and a half years younger than me we
would actually take our blankets and we
would be in our pajamas and we would put
the blanket over the heating vent where
the hot air was coming out from the
furnace and we would huddle under the
blanket just to get warm and then we got
warm enough and we go do some stuff and
then we we'd go do that again as it got
cold and you would wear you know two
pairs of socks and you know you would
wear um you know several different
layers in the house that was the way it
was in the 1970s we were in the middle
of an energy
crisis and um you know just things were
just not warm and I remember being cold
in winter like all the time I was cold
at home I was cold in the car I was cold
on the school bus when we'd get to
school you know parts of the school I
actually went to a little four room
Schoolhouse again in in the little
village of whales uh until they built
the big school you know the big whales
Elementary that we went to from third
grade on and even there it was cold you
know that was a big cinder block
building and it was heated but you know
you you would get cold quite a lot and
this is before they had a lot of the
cold weather gear that we have now you
know much of what we had was wool and
when wool gets wet it's not any fun uh
our socks were continually getting
soaked we actually would save bread bags
from you know loaves of bread and you
would have boots but they weren't
waterproof boots so you would put your
so socks on two pairs of socks and then
You' put bread bags over your feet you
know to be to make them somewhat
waterproof and then you'd shove them
down into your boots and of course your
feet would get sweaty so they wouldn't
stay
entirely uh dry and and you know if
you've ever been in cold weather real
cold weather you really do want to stay
dry it's quite important to to dry off
so that was you know a key part of my
childhood and I remember like going to
my grandparents and my great uncle and
uh you know great aunts places and they
had these wood burning stoves and those
would throw out a lot of heat and you'd
stay close to them right and it was a
dry heat as well uh they also had
electric heat in their houses that was
quite common uh instead of central heat
and you know again you would try to warm
up we would do things like you know
stamp our feet rub our hands together
and sometimes you wouldd even wear
gloves in your place and we had hats you
know it was quite common to have a scarf
and uh a stocking cap that you could
pull down over your face my my great
aunt Tony used to knit us uh things that
were kind of a combination between uh
what they called a tol where this is a
you know French Canadian word for uh
just a hat a n knit hat which has a
beanie or little you know ball on top
but she would knit them so they would
actually be like ski masks and come down
and just our mouth our eyes and our
mouth would have holes in them and you
know she she she knew I was into red
white and blue so I had a red white and
blue one my sister had a uh pink and
white and blue one you know and pastel
colors so it was quite quite a an
interesting time now we would spend a
lot of time outside though you know
during recess if it was really really
bad we wouldn't have to go outside but
typically we had to go outside and play
around so you know we would do things
like throw snowballs at each other and
you know make trails in the snow
sometimes if it the snow was deep enough
and usually by Christmas time we would
actually have snow piled up several feet
high in drifts here and there and then
when it was plowed you might have like
you know uh burms that could be six to8
feet high we would get our shovels out
sometimes they were like snow shovels
and sometimes they're actual Spades and
we would dig forts through the snow we
would
tunnel that's just playing you know we
also sledded because we lived in a hilly
area we were fortunate that we had a uh
wood uh and Hills behind our place and
and quite a few of the um houses
actually were set on top of hill so you
could sled down and that was a lot of
fun and once we had our dog she would
accompany us and run around we throw
snowballs and she'd bite them things
like that and uh so you know you
wouldn't really feel the cold that much
when you were active but then yeah when
you stopped moving it really would get
cold quick and so then you'd go inside
and maybe have some hot chocolate warm
up you know take your your stuff off
open up your layers get some heat into
your body and then go out and play again
and so there were a lot of things that
we used to do some of them chores
outside you had to uh shovel the
driveway when it snowed our driveway was
probably um I don't know maybe somewhere
between an eighth and a quarter of a
mile long so you know we had an
attachment to our tractor that would PLU
that would um uh shoot the snow I forget
exactly what they called it it had like
a spinning blade and it would suck it up
but it wasn't very good it was kind of
underpowered so it would get stuck and
then you'd have to turn it off and get
the snow out if it was heavy and then
you'd have to shovel right even with my
Dad running the tractor me later on
after my dad died running the tractor
you'd be out there with the snow shovel
sometimes while the snow is coming down
and there were other winter sports that
we uh participated in as well um you
know skating was one of them there were
ponds around our place where sometimes
my mom would say hey we're going ice
skating everybody get your skates and
we're going to drive over to this pond
and you know we'd skate for free or you
know sometimes you you'd go to an actual
skating rink and then you had to pay a
little bit of money to to go in there
because it wasn't free but the biggest
thing that we did I remember as a kid
and again this is mostly after my dad
died so we're talking about middle
school and early high
school was was what you call
CrossCountry
skiing and I think we may have started
that in middle school before my dad died
he died in the summer in between my
sixth and seventh grade um but I don't
know that he actually participated with
us because he was he was quite a busy
guy so CrossCountry skiing is um it uses
skis that are long and thin and you may
go up and down Hills but it's not
primarily going downhill that's downhill
skiing right so there you have to
actually go someplace that has mountains
or big Hills or perhaps artificially
constructed ski hills and that's more of
a rich person thing so you know a lot of
the kids at the school that I went to
because I was going to a private school
they would on their coat have all of
these lift tags you know because you
have to go up the ski lift to the top
but then you ski down and that's got
different kinds of skis CrossCountry
skiing at least here in Wisconsin was
more of a you know middle class on
downward sort of thing because you could
rent them very easily at parks there
were other places nearby where you could
you could rent skis but you could also
outfit yourself with the boots and the
skis and the poles for about $100 and
then once you had them you didn't need a
ticket you didn't need anything you
could go around your yard you could go
to a state park which we did many many
times you know I remember going to uh
Scupper Nung in
particular and a couple other parks in
the area and you would just you know
you'd ski away and it was a lot of fun
it's a lot of work it's It's Hard
Exercise but I was in great shape at the
time and aside from your feet getting
cold because there's really almost
nothing you can do with those boots to
to keep your feet warm enough the boots
are kind of thin there's not a lot of
possibility of cramming big thick socks
into them other than that you'd stay
warm just through the exercise you'd
actually unzip your jacket and maybe
take your head off because you'd be
sweating with all of the exertion and I
loved CrossCountry skiing it was really
a fun time you know with my my family
and out there on my own on the trails
you know sometimes the snow would be
falling or you'd be going through this
this icy landscape where the trees would
be covered with snow or ice and uh it
was often quite quite beautiful to do
that and so we did that for many of the
years of my childhood and you know so
there was not just this negative side to
being cold and to Winter there were also
some really fun stuff about it we LED
doing snowball fights I used to roll big
snowballs and and you know instead of
throwing little snowballs I'd lob these
big ones at people I was sort of like
the artillery you could say and you know
we were supposed to not not do that at
school but we did it I actually got put
put into detention because of that um
and had to do some some cleaning of the
ice rink there on a Saturday with the
guy that I threw the snowball at who who
turned me in I got in trouble for
throwing the snowball he got in trouble
for tattling that's the way it was back
in the early
1980s and so um a lot of stuff that we
would do you know in the snow in the
cold um but a lot of the time you'd also
be wet and you know you could get some
some serious pain in your hands and your
feet and your your ears and your nose
and even sometimes you'd have to watch
your your lips as well you had to be
kind of careful and you know use some
chapstick or CarMax to keep your lips
from chapping because of the the dryness
of the winter air and it was interesting
I mentioned Germany so you know I was
stationed as a combat engineer my
regular Duty station was near F uh which
is close to nberg so you know in
southern Germany which is where the
American forces were stationed this is
before the end of the Cold War um so we
are expecting to have to fight against
Warsaw Pact along with our NATO allies
and we would go out on these uh field uh
missions these these field exercises to
graph andir and other places and um one
reason why Wisconsin had Fort McCoy for
a long long time is because the
Wisconsin environment and terrain and
weather is quite similar to that of
Southern Germany not necessarily
Northern or Eastern Germany but Southern
Germany and so it wasn't a huge
adjustment for me to go there as a
matter of fact I will say when I was in
in basic training and AIT uh I was in
Fort leonardwood Missouri and I went
there in February thinking it was going
to actually be a lot nicer weatherwise
than Wisconsin was at the time and it
turned out it was colder and windier in
Missouri quite south of Wisconsin
because you get those those winds coming
down from Canada across the Great Plains
whipping through the woods and it was so
cold that we would fight for each other
we' jockey for position to not be in
somebody's Shadow we wanted that
sunlight to be on us and then they would
transport us around in cattle cars from
place to place and we would just freeze
our butts off right so that was part of
the the being cold all the time as well
from my my
memories so you know cold could be
miserable cold could be bracing cold
could be enjoyable at times if you could
also warm up and uh it all depended on
the situation that you were in and you
just took it as part of life you know
now um people complain about how cold it
is in Winter and I look around and I'm
like this is nothing compared to what we
routinely went through you know snow
piled up feet high uh you know winds
whipping through not having the kind of
cold weather gear that we all uh easily
can get at at you know um department
stores or ordering from places like
llbean or wherever else you're going to
get it it was a quite different time and
so I thought I would share a little bit
of that with you since we're moving now
officially into winter um you know and
we are still here at least I am in
Wisconsin southeastern Wisconsin where I
grew up although in a warmer area of
Milwaukee because we're in a city and
the Great Lake Michigan also stabilizes
the weather not like being out in the
the countryside where it it was a lot
more snow and a lot more cold I thought
maybe I'd share that with you and maybe
some of you might be saying oh you know
I come from a much colder area what you
have down there in Wisconsin that's
nothing you know but many of you might
be from warmer climbs as well and so
maybe this could be something quite
interesting to you to hear about and
it's something that's been on my mind
the last couple days and as I've been
you know taking walks in the cold and
spending time out and about and as the
the seasons are changing and we get
closer and closer to the official
beginning of
winter